Republicans warning terrorists could be
infiltrating America's wide open border
after the horrific attacks in Israel
over 150 people on the FBI's Terror
watch list have been arrested Crossing
into the US so far this year and that
has Kevin McCarthy sounding this alarm
just in this year alone there's
151 from 160 different countries in my
own State we caught two coming from
Yemen on the terrorist watch list from
China and others
why are they coming to America what do
they have planned and who are they
communicating with President Biden has
said previously that he believes the
number one threat to America is facing
is climate change the number one threat
killing
Americans is
Terrorism the number one threat is an
open border a shocking new Congressional
report finding that the Biden
Administration has failed to remove
99% of illegal immigrants reled relased
into the country and new border patrol
data shows thousands of special interest
aliens from places like Syria Yemen Iran
and Afghanistan have come into the US
illegally Greg you alluded to this in
the a block as saying that yes we've got
a problem there but we've got we got a
serious problem here on our own border
yeah I mean the non border is actually a
symptom of absolute weakness uh for
we've in this country I don't know why
but in the last I'd say 20 years we've
demonized
strength as a characteristic of the
oppressor so anytime you exercise any
kind of strength discipline or will
that's somehow wrong it's the same way
that we handcuff the police during the
riots or Commerce in response to
shoplifting or any kind of crime we are
governed by the weakest group of people
in our nation's history you could grab a
class of auto mechanics from a trade
school put them in charge and you'd get
a better outcome because weak men love
weak borders I mean even the world of
Barbie had a border I don't know if you
saw that movie but uh again I mean you
you you know we talk about uh he said
that the the biggest threat was climate
change he he also said the biggest
threat domestic threat was white
supremacy right uh think of the
opportunity cost there what we lost in
Safety and Security because Joe
preferred to indulge the left-wing drug
called identity politics because you
know it made those faculty lounges like
him uh we are now in a state of weakness
where we at our most vulnerable we had
we never at a time of we had such a weak
Administration and such a huge threat to
coincide at the same time judge the
other thing that comes to mind is that
it's not just that you have uh people on
the terror watch list coming across the
border IL legally and staying in one
place now they're they could be anywhere
in the country and how do you track them
you can they can be anywhere and we're
not going to track them because we don't
I mean we let them in I think it was in
uh in in 2021 as as you said 99% of the
migrants who came in are staying in the
United States and that's 2 million
people 99% now let's talk about Hamas if
anybody thinks that Hamas is not already
in this country I think they're naive
because when you think about it that
what happened in Israel is about the
extinction of the Jewish race it's not
about territory and if Hamas hates Jews
you know they're in this country as well
and what the Biden Administration has
done is he has allowed a wholesale
entrance he's made this this country
nothing more than a global landing spot
with Benefits no questions no DNA no
nothing and even if they do tell you you
have to go to court you don't have to go
for another six or seven years right I
mean we look like fools on the world
stage and you know Michael Waltz
Congressman indicated that there's a
history of Iran's Islamic revolutionary
guard corpse working with the Mexican
drug cartels to enter through our open
border so we and and think about it
Israel is the little Satan we are the
great Satan it we are inextricably tied
to Israel and we have allowed Hamas to
come into this country along with all
kinds of people one and a half million
getaways we don't even know who they are
right we got a problem and if they would
have even been on the Terra watch list
because you because you don't know Brian
it was an opportunity so he knows he's
got a huge problem on the border not
because Greg says so although he should
be listening to you but because the
mayor of New York City the mayor of
Chicago the governor of Massachusetts
the governor of New York everyone is
telling him you got a huge problem here
now this happens in that speech that uh
mostly was good he could have said
listen title 42 is back in place this is
our version of the pandemic uh if my my
number one thing as a president United
States is to keep the American people
safe I don't want to take any chances I
just saw the number that Dana put up it
has Iranians that have come here uh 659
uh over the last two years on the terror
watch list so I think that this is a
reason not on ter watchus but have come
through here and have registered I think
that's a problem Pakistan as well
they've been a problem in the past Syria
has is a big terrorist State 538 Yemen
as well so I think the president use
this opportunity I'm putting title 42
I'm going to be tied on Iran he'd have
better prospects on the election to be
really cynical how about just close CL
the Border yeah but he needs an
apparatus to do to do his job evidently
uh last word to you Jessica you never
want to be on the wrong end of a
declarative statement like X is the
biggest threat right because something
else can show up I mean before 911 we
didn't think that there would be
terrorists that got Pilots licenses and
were hiding out you know in in and
around us and then we're able to take
nearly 3,000 lives right but that's the
expectation now that something like that
is possible so of course it is possible
that somebody God forbid could leak
through on a border but it is important
to consider the facts about this at
least up until this point so I went back
and looked at testimony from someone who
works at the KO Institute he went before
the subcommittee on immigration
Integrity security and enforcement in
September he said zero Americans have
been injured or killed in terrorist
attacks by illegal immigrants or Asylum
Seekers who entered through the the
southern border and over the period from
1975 to 2022 the chance of being
murdered in an attack by a foreign born
terrorist was one in 4.3 million per
Anna that's just important to consider
in all of this I understand that you
want certain things from President Biden
I don't necessarily thinking this isn't
because I don't care about the border
that today's speech was about that
today's speech was about Israel and he
had just gotten off the phone with
Netanyahu who obviously expressed to him
what his priorities were in terms of
what he'd like to hear but do keep that
in the back of your mind as you say that
now like Kevin McCarthy you know this is
the number one threat it based on the
data it AB it absolutely isn't until it
is until it is all right hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now